are the concepts super super important
like the trigonometry that we learned
last year where directly sort of drawing
on it now and we're going to keep on
drawing on these results later on when
we do to particular parts of the
extension course namely simple harmonic
motion which is what happens when you
have an object like say um a a boat
that's on a tire and it goes up and down
up and down just sort of oscillates in
this way and you can see if something
goes up and down and you consider it
over time then the shape that it traces
out is surprise-surprise a sine wave or
a cosine wave doesn't really matter
right and so that's simple harmonic
motion we will also look at projectile
motion which is when you you know you
throw something through the air or you
you fire it like a projectile from a
cannon or say that those are the typical
questions so more surprisingly those
also use these same results so this is a
really big deal okay right so yesterday
we cover the theory of this and if some
of it sort of sailed over your head do
not fret big new ideas and they take
time to sort of soak into your brain so
if you looked at yesterday's and you're
like that was really hard
don't panic yes it was really hard we're
going to focus on using those now and if
the theoretical underpinning isn't quite
there yet give it some time but I want
us to review what these key results were
that we actually from scratch that I was
so hard we derive these results proper
use of the word deriving in that case so
I wonder if you remember what were the
three derivatives that we came up with
what do we start with with science the
easiest one sign just differentiates to
cosign that was a nice simple one cosign
when you differentiate it does it
doesn't go back to sign it goes back to
negative sign now we did the visual on
on this well we didn't do the visual on
this there and this is worth actually
very you know on the side if you like
doing a very very brief drawing on it
just draw a regular cosine curve you
just need to draw bless you just not two
pi will do so that's what cosine looks
like now if you think about it visually
like we did with sine and you think
about what its derivative is doing
you see from nought up into a certain
spot I'm gonna ask you what that spot is
in a second from naught to a certain
spot it's a decreasing function where
does it stop being a decreasing function
what value one x value it's gonna be
there right do you see that that's where
it's no longer decreasing and what is
that value that's that's pyrite so from
naught to PI the gradient is negative
and then from PI to 2 pi the gradient is
positive now if you then think about
that your graph for your gradient
function is gonna be down here
there's my negative part there's my
stationary point there and there and
then this part which is an increasing
function your gradient function should
be positive that is not side it's upside
down side and that's why you've got that
minus sign at the front ok so if you
can't remember which ones which because
it does get confusing just wait till we
throw integration in the mix we've
already found a bit confusing when you
forget whether you're differentiating or
you're integrating this is where more
confusing because look at how how easy
it is to mix these up which is why I'm
very consciously not talking about
integration yet ok we want to get these
bedded down now head 10 was the last one
we looked at 10 is more complicated
because it's actually a question it's
sine over cos so it's derivative is also
a little more complicated remember what
it was SEC squared very good now I asked
you to get your reference sheet out
there are a bunch of spots on the
reference sheet that refer to these I
only want to refer to one of them if you
have a look bear with me here pull open
your reference sheet and you can see on
you've got the cover page and then
you've got page one which has some point
geometry stuff series and sequences then
when you have a look at page two this is
where the calculus really kicks in so
you can see the derivatives there on
your left the integrals there on your
right we will not look at those
integrals just yet I don't want to
confuse you but have a look at the
derivatives do you see the derivatives
of the trigonometric functions now those
are similar but not exactly what I've
written here what's the difference
between the results they have given us
and these results they have an f of X so
in other words they're thinking about it
in the context of chain
rule right if you don't just have
regular sine X if you have sign of
something else right some other function
in here then chain rule works just like
normal and even though you have it there
on your reference sheet I want you to
write with me the chain rule versions of
each of these we want to get them into
our head okay so if you are
differentiating the sign of an function
that isn't just X something a little
more complicated and we're going to do
an example of this a concrete example in
like 30 seconds then we're going to
treat this just like we've been treating
chain rule function of function rule for
everything else there's an inside
function this guy we need it's
derivative and then there's an outside
function which in this case is sine and
we need its derivative as well so if my
inside function is f what will its
derivative be F - right there's the
inside derivative now when you
differentiate sine of something what
does it become it becomes cos of
something whatever that something
happens to be so that's why as you'll
see on your reference sheet you get a
cause after that right so as an example
a concrete one if we were
differentiating sine of x squared plus
one this is okay sine of a function
what's the inside derivative in this
case it's just going to be 2x you've
dealt with the inside now you deal with
the outside its sign good morning sine
becomes cosine when you differentiate it
so it'll be cause of x squared plus one
are you happy with that
inside outside we're done the rest of
these I want to do the concrete example
cuz I can I think you can see how it
works but if I were to differentiate cos
of a function
humor me what's the derivative of the
inside then inside the inside it's gonna
be just F - right the derivative of the
outside cause will differentiate into
negative sign so a bit awkward I don't
wanna put them negative here I'm gonna
put it probably out the front where it
belongs and that becomes sign okay with
that so what we're writing here are the
trigonometric versions of the chain rule
okay we'll finish ten and then we'll
come back to remember what the other
ones are derivative of tan of a function
one last time derivative of the inside
half - and then the outside is tabbed so
I know what happens to turn it
differentiates to become sick squared
sick squared and don't forget because
it's of a function you end up with that
function coming all the way through it's
a very common error to think oh I got
the inside the outside is just 10 it
becomes sex squared X even if the inside
function wasn't originally X so just
watch out fat it's a very common error
to make okay